floodwaters cover the streets of mughlai  in central bosnia the only way to reach  the city center is by helicopter or by  boat there's no electricity and food is  running out residents have camped out on  the roofs of homes waiting to be rescued  the floods have hit Bosnia especially  hard many of these homes were built  quite recently as the country rebuilt  after the Bosnian war of the 1990s  floods have also ravaged parts of  neighboring Serbia in a Brenna vods two  rivers burst their banks the water was  up to three metres deep in some parts of  the town volunteers have brought around  4,000 people to safety men evacuees are  now living in shelters in the capital  Thomas Mazzilli tell if we just grabbed  our cell phones and ran out I even  forgot my ID the whole house is under  water and so is the gardens that problem  when i vecchi boy tunisia the EU and  Russia have promised aid Germany has  sent experts from its disaster relief  agency